all right john
no john where'd you grow up where are
you from original uh las vegas nevada
las vegas
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid
i bought my parents until the age of six
and uh
that my father passed away uh yeah he
took his own life
but uh yeah i had my mom growing up
uh then she came into a stepfather or
then i came into a stepfather and then i
have a
my brother and sister for my stepfather
and my mother
and then i have another sister from my
father's side
how did you describe your childhood
pretty good
uh a lot of depression and stuff i used
to go in and out of uh counseling and
stuff
so just because my father's passing away
what do you think was the cause of your
father's suicide uh i think depression
yeah
he was he was going to break up with his
his wife at the time so i think that had
a lot to do with it
break up with your mom uh my stepmother
oh i say okay yeah
and do you have uh suicidal tendencies
you think uh
no that's something that i kind of grew
up against uh
hating i i kind of a hate towards uh
you know killing yourself and stuff like
that
but i always had passion compassion for
ones that felt like they needed to do
that stuff to themselves or anything
so yeah i think it's more than just i
think the brain chemistry comes into it
and then
it's almost like our quality of life
something kind of
tells us that we don't want to be alone
you know we kind of
once we have friends in our life and you
know could talk about other things you
kind of
we don't think about that simultaneously
or anything so yeah
do you have friends some friends and not
really
yeah living on the street you have
acquaintances i've learned
yeah yeah and that's basically it it's
just acquaintances
like the guy that i ran into recently
he's pretty cool guy
you know it's a everybody's kind of out
there for their money
and stuff like that so which is
understandable being on the street but
what i don't understand is how people
they're they're on the street they're
making all this money hustling and stuff
and they stay on the street
i i never quite uh understood that no
you've been in l.a how long oh three
months three months
yeah and you were homeless in vegas too
yeah i was homeless for about two years
in vegas
so yeah maybe a little longer but where
are you staying now
i'm staying in a tent with my friend
yeah okay
what do you think of skid row uh
i think is the streets seem
dirty like it seems like it seems like
the trash
cans and stuff they just overfilled and
stuff sometimes
i never quite know uh
what that's about i don't know how often
the the city comes and do
does their thing but in all fairness i
haven't been paying attention like that
i've been up in echo park and are you
getting around
yeah trying to get around so but at
first it kind of seemed dirty a lot of a
lot of food and trash on the grounds and
stuff
and i don't see a lot of birds so
back to your childhood what kind of kid
were you in high school
in high school i liked school work but i
didn't like homework
homework was something that i never
completed but i love to stay busy in
school
i love that type of stuff you graduated
high school no i never graduated i
dropped out
i started using drugs and selling drugs
at a young age so i ended up dropping
out
how far did you go uh 10th grade okay
yeah
and what drugs are you playing around
with uh it's like oxycontin
stuffs like that just started coming out
pretty big back then
so yeah i remember when i first started
selling or whatever actually gotten to
like five dollars a piece and
nowadays if you were to find one it'd be
100 plus okay
and you've been using ever since uh i
had a couple years sobriety in between
uh i found out that was like the best
the best times of my life is
you know being sober and having a
direction to go in and
you know kind of having my pro
productive proactive type of self your
happiest when you're clean
yeah yeah
my personality it's just one of those
personalities to say if it's there
and you're trying to do it uh uh not
that i'm seeking to do it but
if you offer then i won't turn it down
i'm kind of one of those stuff yeah and
the self-control is
yeah yeah and then once once it's there
it's like oh that's fun
yeah you know because i never quite have
the building bridge or the
the steps and out of that path you know
i i have the doing drugs down but
i don't have the to go get it to go to
the next door
and or whatever you know the next
opportunity and you know line up my i
need to fill up my whole day
you know with uh productive type stuff
so and what is your drug today
uh it's heroin now because uh
pills and stuff you can't really find
anymore but uh
i i wish there was pills on the streets
again because it's a little more
consistent
you know it seems a little more
healthier for people that uh
that do the drug you know other than
finding other types of drugs and the
hair when it's cut sometimes
yeah they cut it sometimes uh i've had
hair when they kind of
tasted like a battery you know recently
and
it's just that i like consistency i i
just rather have that type of
thing to if i were stuck using something
that's what i would rather be stuck with
is something that's uh
the fda approves and knows more about
and
there's probably more more ways to help
people
you know through the system and stuff
like that as well so
have you encountered fentanyl uh yeah
yeah i haven't encountered fentanyl
it's a it's just another one of those
highs
it's an immediate high yeah if you smoke
it
um but it's
it's really a a fine there's like a
sheer line i call it a shear line drug
it uh there's a shear to it that uh
it's quite nasty it uh i'm not sure how
to explain it but it yes
it's not that great of a drug have you a
deed but it but it is a decent drug if
you were uh
like i've had fentanyl suckers and stuff
i've done it the proper way
but uh yeah i've never od no
no but i i hear that is a that's a
pretty strong uh
strong drug to od on yeah yeah a lot of
people die from it
yeah that's right here and how do you
support yourself now uh
it's been panhandling and things like
that until i can find
work i like i really want to work i just
i don't have my id
so yeah
what is what is spending your day
panhandling due to your
self-esteem uh it's something that
i started building the okay with you
know
i started doing it every day so i became
uh okay with
being a panhandler or something it was
just a
just something that changes your life a
title
it's it's really different than going
out and working every day and talking to
people and coming back
you just say the the repetitious things
able to spare any change sir
what kind of reactions do you get from
people
there's a lot of nose or head shaking
and but there's a lot of there's a lot
of cool people out there that you know
they're willing to give you a buck or
two or so that's pretty cool
how much were you collecting a day
probably like 20 or 40 bucks if if i
were sitting out there doing it but
i'm more the type of person i was just
trying to you know go score a sack or
something like that so
it's just like ten dollars and then i
try to leave i
kind of don't like to panhandle yeah
how old are you 33 33 you have kids uh i
have one daughter
and where is she uh in las vegas with
her mother
yeah you stay in contact with her uh no
i haven't
i need to though
and uh so looking back at your life i
mean what
you've been living on the streets for a
long time and you're you've been using
drugs for
even longer what what regrets do you
have what
what have you learned uh is it well i
could tell it's probably getting to my
physical health a little bit
you know uh sometimes you get worried
you're like well if i start exercising
and start sweating it out
but sometimes you just think that it
might be a little too deep
deeper than that so it's probably a good
time to start taking care of myself
definitely
yeah definitely you know finding like a
i don't know like a softball league or
something to get a part of or
just something to stay active what
emotions do you
do you deal with uh
i deal with anger uh
i i don't really deal with violence i
don't really have much violence in me
uh uh sadness depression
absolutely it's hard not to get
depressed living this life right
yeah and then a lot of it recently is
just noticing how my body might be
changing and stuff like
you know just taking the wear and tear
so i i just think a lot
about stuff like that or i notice
more than i think about it you know i
just uh
yeah and certainly you're intelligent
enough to know that this is not a
healthy good lifestyle for you or your
daughter
yeah absolutely what do you think people
don't understand that don't do drugs
uh about addiction i think the main
thing is you're just looking for a
quality of life
you know in in doing drugs you're
looking for the the quality of life that
you have
you know whether the drugs is a fun
moment or
something like that i think once you
find
what the quality what gives you quality
of life
you know and the main thing is to stay
busy throughout your whole day
you know if you could stay busy
throughout your whole day and enjoy what
you're doing throughout the whole day
your quality of life
into turning around well
it starts having a better score so then
you don't
you know repetitious practice of that
will get you off of drugs and
you know and then you just start
noticing your life turning around and
different opportunities falling in your
lap and
stuff like that when you got clean would
you you say you've been clean before for
a couple years yeah
how did you do it you know working out
i had a job and then working out so
you know when you have a job and you're
working long hours your routine keeps
you clean
yeah because you're tired enough to go
to sleep and then you
you have something scheduled already
when you wake up so
it just it becomes that cycle that ends
up
filling your days up then you get paid
and then
you get to look at all the the cool
things like paying rent's a cool thing
to do and
you know all those things become you
becoming an adult
and a lot of it i think is just growing
up and
taking on some responsibility yeah
definitely for paying the rent and bills
and taxes absolutely
yeah that's down here on skate road you
have no responsibility at all right
absolutely i think a lot of people just
get comfortable with that and yeah
because we like to like we like to be
who we are we like to show who we are as
a good
strong person you know reliable and
stuff like that so i think
responsibility
is a big thing like that definitely
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
stay hydrated
and i'm from las vegas so it's kind of
different but if you do do drugs or
anything like that
stay hydrated for sure just uh
keep your keep your body as smart as it
is already
you know and it's able to flush and
clean a lot of that stuff
out of you so that's probably the
biggest lesson i learned
interesting yeah all right john well
thank you so much for sharing your story
all right thank you i wish you the best
of luck thanks
you